non-minimalists
why is it that some people cling to
toxic jobs or work environments
i have a good answer for that one yeah
what is it it's security it's the
paycheck at the end of the day it's the
health insurance
it's the 401k it's
the security that comes with working for
a large corporation that's why i stuck
in a really toxic job for a long time
yeah let's talk about that toxic job so
it was toxic in what ways it was making
you miserable i i didn't share the
values that the company shared they were
more it was a medical company so i
thought
helping people helping people get
healthy that's something i could
really be a part of and enjoy and then
once i actually got there and learned
more and
saw more it's all about the money
it wasn't about seeing people as
patients and as individuals it was how
many people can you see in a day
how can you get the most money for each
transaction and
i had a really hard time with that
especially because i got to call these
people and ask them for money
and when you're talking to people day
after day who can't afford it and need
medical care it's just it's really
disheartening and sad and it really
reflects on our
our society in general and how we don't
take care of
each other and
so the value part was really
a lot of it was
that and then also
it's funny because it was a medical
clinic but to reward us and to motivate
us
they um just stuffed us full of candies
and donuts
and um
so i got very sick at that job
um
so i think those were the main things
but i wanted to stay because i made good
money i had a secure future that seemed
a lot more secure than trying to do
something on my own yeah i mean we would
rather
cling to what we know good or bad
helpful or not helpful whatever you want
to look at it serving us or not serving
us we'd rather cling to what we know
rather than
take our chances with some with the
unknown essentially
so i mean that's yeah that's why i clung
to my corporate job was the same exact
reason i was like oh where am i going to
go
and make this much money because i
needed to make that much money
uh to pay my debt payments because those
i needed to have those debt payments to
in order to own things to make me happy
and
yeah the context was just um
just keep holding on it'll get better
eventually yeah yeah and it just kept
getting worse and worse but
but yeah i mean it's there's all there's
also something there about like
it you know we talked uh about you know
learning to
love yourself with mel robbins and
accepting yourself for who you are and
seeing yourself in the mirror and really
appreciating who you see
um but there's also something with
trusting yourself
and like for me
and i remember i used to always say this
to you like we'd see a homeless person
and i'd be like you know josh like just
imagine how many decisions we are away
from being homeless or being in that you
know being in that situation and one one
time you said to me you're like dude
that will never happen to me like i
wouldn't make those i'm just the type of
person i wouldn't make those decisions
like i would figure it out and really
what i hear you talking about is how you
trust yourself to like figure it out to
make it work yeah
and i don't know how to help someone get
to that point of trusting in themselves
but um
in a way people who cling to these jobs
cling to the paychecks they don't trust
themselves
and uh
yeah i again i don't know how i don't
know how i got there i don't know how
you got there i don't know how you got
there but
um there is work to be done if you're
clinging to a miserable situation
there there's some internal work to be
done to help you
trust yourself a little bit more i think
it has to do with the stories that we
tell ourselves yeah we tell ourselves
story about money is the most important
thing and what do we do then we diminish
the things that are actually important
to us it's not that money is unimportant
it's that it's not as important as
real security because the security
you're talking about mariah is a
misnomer because that company could have
gone out of business so they could have
outsourced your job there wasn't real
security there it was a sense of faux
security right and so we cling to that
sense of faux security that faux
certainty because we're so uncomfortable
with uncertainty or at least we think we
are but of course we all love variety
which is just a kind way to say
uncertainty and so we seek out variety
or novelty
and we avoid uncertainty
we seek out uncertainty and avoid
uncertainty it doesn't make any sense
but it has to do with the stories we
tell ourselves and it also has to do
with hope i hope this job will get
better now we don't have any evidence
that it's going to get any better but
we cling to this idea of well if i just
do this long enough if i stick it out if
i remain disciplined
then maybe something will change now
maybe it will
but if you don't have any evidence for
that
then
holding out hope in a scenario like that
is actually a way to
to keep us stuck in a place that we
don't want to be stuck in there's a
different kind of hope we can have i
hope that if i walk away from this
then there will be something else
as you said trusting yourself having
faith in yourself yeah
i can have faith in myself the homeless
thing is
it was actually the most empathetic
thing because what i was talking about
there is i'm probably two decisions away
of course
from being that person who's literally
across the street from here right now
camped out
from our studio
and also you know mental illness runs in
my family and a lot of america's
homelessness problem has to do with
mental illness which is exacerbated by
drug and alcohol abuse yeah right and so
you know 40 of the males in my family
are schizophrenic 40
wow so that certainly could have
happened to me for whatever reason it
didn't
i not
i have no control over that right
and um and yet
so i'm in some ways zero decisions away
from that happening
you know i see me in that person
one unfortunate circumstance could have
led me to be the guy that is across the
street and so i have
extreme empathy for that so much so that
like i don't even
it's so troubling to me because i don't
know what to do
like there are times where i want to
help
but i know that often the things that i
can do to help
will make the situation worse
and so
it's paralyzing right yeah back to the
job thing why are we clinging to these
these
toxic
work environments well it's because we
want something different and we think we
can get it out of there
and we know that it gives us the
certainty we're terrified of the
uncertainty
and so what we're really clinging to is
not the job we're not clinging to the
work environment we're clinging to that
sense of certainty
if i can be certain about this
at least i won't be devastated by
uncertainty
what's the antidote to that we tell
ourselves better stories
about the way things are right now we
tell ourselves the truth not some
exaggerated made up thing things suck
right now
and here's the 10 reasons they suck with
mariah it's like hey i have to do
something that is against my values i
have to show up every morning at a time
where i don't want to show up i have to
be exposed to all of these you know the
candies and donuts who who was it that
uh said
um i think it was jay krishnamurti is as
um
if someone places donuts in front of me
i lose my freedom
[Music]
yeah and so late isn't that
and so you're setting yourself up in
these environments and as soon as you
start articulating what the truth of it
is yeah the money is one that's one
truth as well yes i make good money
that's part of the truth
but it's a narrow sliver of it and we
focus on that tiny little sliver oh i'm
making money and we forsake all the
things that are important to us all the
things we value we forsake the people
around us we forsake our health we
forsake our contentment just to make a
little bit of money and just to hold on
to a little bit of certainty which
doesn't even exist in the first place
yeah
i don't know why but i'm just feeling
really
compassionate towards people who
because it's not just the money for them
it's the money for their wife and their
kids their household
and they have all of these
responsibilities that they feel like
well this is the best way for me to like
meet their needs
i'm trying to think of a different
perspective because um
because there are people out there like
that who who
they can't just leave their job well i
mean i actually we're never suggesting
anyone just leave their job that would
be silly to just quit your job and start
a blog or quit your job and start a
podcast yes um you can do that it's not
that you should or shouldn't do it right
right right right i think there's
another story we tell ourselves and you
use the the term here the
responsibilities i have
i think sometimes we think we have
certain responsibilities that we don't
actually have sometimes yeah i'm
responsible for you and you and you and
you and and it makes us feel ver feel
virtuous about who we are look how
responsible i am right we often in
especially in our country we talk about
all of our rights
and then if we're really feeling
virtuous we talk about our
responsibilities
these are just concepts we make these
things up these are stories we tell
ourselves i have the right to this
i have the right to do no no no you
don't actually yes it's in a document
somewhere
right but
i also don't have all the
responsibilities that i've told myself
and it's not even me telling it's not
your fault or my fault society has told
us well you have certain
responsibilities and you should be a
responsible adult
but what does that even mean oh we're
making this up and so all the
responsibilities you have yes you might
have some
but are a lot of them faux
responsibilities are you telling
yourself you're responsible for things
that you actually have no responsibility
for whatsoever if so maybe that's part
of the disempowering story that we can
stop clinging to yeah yeah i love it
yeah i'm just i i don't know why it came
into mind but yeah i'm just thinking how
can we help people tell a different
story who were in that situation did you
enjoy this video if so you can listen to
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free